وفي غزة الليلة، شنت قوات الدفاع الإسرائيلية غارة ثانية
على مخيم جباليا، حيث قال الجيش الإسرائيلي إنها
كانت ضربة مستهدفة لحماس بالطبع على
الرغم من أن العديد من المدنيين الأبرياء
يبدو أنهم قتلوا أيضًا. ناداب بشير
موجود في المقدمة في القدس وأريد أن
أحذرك من أن بعضًا من  الصور الواردة في
تقريرها هي الفوضى
المصورة والرعب في
مخيم جباليا للاجئين في غزة، حيث هرع الأطفال الجرحى
إلى سيارات الإسعاف القريبة، أحدث
ضحايا القصف الجوي الإسرائيلي المتواصل على
هذا
الحي المكتظ بالسكان والذي يسيطر عليه الذعر وعدم
التصديق، غارة جوية إسرائيلية ثانية في
أقل من 24
ساعة
تقول قوات الدفاع إنها كانت
تستهدف مجمع القيادة والسيطرة التابع لحماس
في جباليا، ويقال إن مقاتلي حماس
كانوا من بين القتلى، لكن جباليا هي
موطن لأكثر من 100.000 مدني
وفقًا للأمم المتحدة، وفي حين أن
المدى الكامل لعدد القتلى المدنيين لا
يزال غير واضح في هذه المرحلة
وقد وصفت هيئة الدفاع المدني في غزة
هذه الكارثة الأخيرة بأنها مذبحة، حيث تم
إضافة المزيد من الضحايا والمزيد من القتلى إلى قائمة المئات الذين قيل إنهم
قتلوا أو جرحوا في الغارة الجوية التي وقعت يوم الثلاثاء.
ومن الصعب على العديد من
السكان استيعاب حجم الدمار في جباليا.  لا يزال
عمال الإنقاذ والمدنيون مدفونين تحت الأنقاض السوداء، وهم
يحفرون جنبًا إلى جنب يائسين للعثور على
ناجين، وانظر إلى هارون، لقد رأينا
هذه الغارات الجوية مستمرة في قصف
أجزاء من شمال غزة، وهذه هي المنطقة
التي حذر فيها جيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي المدنيين
والسكان من الإخلاء باتجاه الجنوب.  محذراً
من أن تلك الضربات الجوية سوف تتكثف،
ولكن كما رأينا على مدار
الأسابيع الثلاثة الماضية، فإن أكثر من ثلاثة أسابيع
الآن تتواصل تلك الضربات الجوية
في جميع أنحاء قطاع غزة، ليس فقط في
الشمال ولكن في وسط وجنوب غزة
أيضًا فيما يسمى  المناطق الآمنة، بما في ذلك
المناطق التي يلجأ إليها الكثيرون،
بما في ذلك مدارس الأمم المتحدة، وبالنسبة للكثيرين داخل
غزة في الوقت الحالي، فإن الخوف بالنسبة لهم هو أنه
ببساطة لا يوجد مكان آمن لتحويل
إيرين